une salle pleine dans le procès en appel
des deux meurtriers de clément méric
assassiné le 5 juin 2013 ce militant
anti fasciste s'est retrouvé au milieu
d'une rixe entre une bande de skinheads
et puis une bande d'antifascistes
c'était en juin 2013 aux alentours de
saint lazare la séance a commencé avec
différentes plaidoiries à commencer par
celle de l'avocat général qui est revenu
longuement sur les circonstances de
cette soirée cette soirée fatidique qui
a coûté l avis aux jeunes anti-fascistes
il est revenu également sur le profil
des deux prévenus à savoir samuel du
coup rester ben morillo il est revenu
également sur une intention au concret
de violence une intention concrètes d'en
découdre comme a dit l'avocat général il
a finit sa plaidoirie après 2h en
s'adressant directement aux deux accusés
je cite j'ose espérer que depuis ce
drame vous avez pris des distances avec
cette idéologie est mortifère mais
aujourd'hui il faut rendre des comptes à
la société il a eu un mot également
l'avocat général sur ce que vous voulez
a plaidé la défense à savoir la légitime
défense l'avocat général est revenu sur
l'autopsié du jeune anti-fasciste aucune
lésion de défense a déclaré le médecin
elle les jce ce qui pousse l'avocat
général a repoussé et rejeter cette
légitime défense
ensuite c'était au tour de l'avocat des
avocats de la défense qui ont plaidé
près de quatre heures pour samuel du
cours et pour rester devant morio je
vous propose d'écouter à ce sujet
l'avocat de samuel dufour nous sommes
étonnés d'avoir eu les mêmes
réquisitions en appel qu'en première
instance parce que la première instance
avait été extrêmement politique et
l'audience d'appel a été beaucoup plus
apaisé nous avons passé beaucoup de
temps sur les éléments du dossier
nous semblait mais nous sommes en
défense que les éléments du dossier
pointé vers le fait que les skins ne
voulait pas la bagarre
il était d'ailleurs en infériorité
numérique ça s'est avéré qu'ils avaient
peur au moment de sortir dans la rue et
tout laisse à penser qu'ils se sont fait
tomber dessus et que malheureusement un
mauvais coup de poing entraîné le
déséquilibre puis le décès de clément
amérique
c'est une vraiment c'est une triste
histoire une triste histoire de bandes
comme on en voit régulièrement il
s'avère que là ce sont des bandes
politiques parfois ce sont des bandes
qui sont sur une base géographique
dans les deux cas c'est très malheureux
de voir un jeune homme de 19 ans
perdraient après plus de huit heures de
plaidoiries dans une salle comble place
aux délibérations l'avocat général
souhaite voir ces deux individus
condamnés pour violences volontaires en
réunion avec arme ayant entraîné l la
mort et le même réquisitoire qu'en
première instance à savoir sept ans de
prison pour samuel dufour et 11 ans de
prison pour esteban morillo le verdict
est attendu dans la nuit